mille euros nets de retraite par mois
pour les agriculteurs à partir de 2022
sur le papier la réforme devrait réjouir
le monde agricole
en moyenne les retraites s'élève à 760
euros par mois pour les hommes et 580
pour les femmes selon un rapport de
l'insee de 2016 des pensions en dessous
de la moyenne française 1390 euros en
2017 selon l'insee et du seuil de
pauvreté 2010 9041 euros problème cette
réforme est loin de concerner tous les
agriculteurs
seuls les chefs d'exploitation ayant
fait une carrière complète de 43 ans
ayant cotisé à hauteur du smic pourront
en bénéficier sont exclues notamment les
conjoints des agriculteurs qui
travaillent dans l'exploitation ou
encore les agriculteurs qui ont connu
des interruptions dans leurs activités
pour diverses raisons
40% des paysans ne serait donc pas
éligibles à cette retraite plancher
selon le rapport de le voir une
désillusion donc pour les agriculteurs
ben oui mille euros ça peut être correct
parce que dans les conditions de vie
qu'on peut avoir ou les trains de vie
qu'on peut avoir
voilà ça peut être quelque chose de bien
après les conditions si elles sont trop
compliqués très longue peut-être qu'on
aura de toute façon jamais non plus 7 7
semble aujourd'hui la retraite des
paysans je veux comme mes parents c'est
ses 700 ou 800 euros maximum
donc on entend dire un mille euros on
sait déjà un premier pas mais c'est un
crime en cage
il faudrait même un peu plus parce que
c'est vrai que vis-à-vis des autres
corporations on est on risque d'être
encore à la traîne quand même autre
revendication
l'application de ce plafond de 1000
euros aux agriculteurs déjà à la
retraite
ça fait plus de deux ans qu'on réclame
cette revalorisation des retraites
agricoles qui est
13 mars et qui est même la plus basse
aujourd'hui eux
en france qu' on nous a mis en avant
justement le remaniement de 7
de l'ensemble des retraites pour
l'ensemble des corporations et que
aujourd'hui on est en stand by on attend
toujours une revalorisation aujourd'hui
sur le terrain on voit des gens qui
veulent plus prendre la retraite parce
qu'ils ont intérêt à continuer à faire
leur métier alors qu'ils ont dépassé
l'âge espoirs balayé par emmanuel macron
samedi dernier au salon de l'agriculture
tous ceux qui rentreront dans le nouveau
système contrairement à l'ancien ils
auront une garantie de retraite minimum
est ce que je peux vous dire tous les
agriculteurs retraités d'aujourd'hui
peuvent rentrer c'est impossible c'est
impossible parce que c'est un coude 1,1
milliard et incompréhension des
syndicats qui réclament une
revalorisation des pensions des 1,3
million d'agriculteurs déjà à la
retraite qu'aujourd'hui on a eu and yet
samedi du président de la république sur
ce public là nous on demande à ce qu'ils
aient une reprise de ces retraités
actuels aujourd'hui si c'est pas dans la
loi et on savait très bien que ce ne
serait pas dans la loi que ce soit
traitée en parallèle et on avait quand
même des engagements de la ministre de
la santé qui est plus là aujourd'hui
agnès buzyn comme quoi ça serait traitée
en parallèle la loi aujourd'hui le
président de la république
notez que ça sera traité dans la
prochaine loi de finances on a besoin de
certitudes et de faire application
cette revalorisation pourrait donc voir
le jour dans la prochaine loi de
finances mais à condition que des
propositions de financement soit fait
selon le ministère de l'agriculture
malgré la réforme qu'ils soient déjà
retraités ou non
nombreux sont les agriculteurs qui
devront donc compter sur le minimum
vieillesse